Carol daners also known as Captain
Marvel is one of the most powerful
heroes in the universe but how did she
get her incredible abilities when she
was a former United States Air Force
pilot who worked with Dr Wendy Lawson
Lawson was working on a project called
the light speed engine which used the
energy of the Tesseract Carol tried to
destroy the engine to prevent it from
falling into the wrong hands but the
explosion infused her with Cosmic Powers
next up is Kamala Khan our beloved Miz
Marvel Camala is a 16-year-old Pakistani
American High School student one day
Camala discovered that she had super
Powers when she accidentally activated a
family heirloom Bengal that belonged to
her grandmother the Bengal allowed her
to manipulate nor a mysterious cosmic
energy that flows through all living
things last but not least we have Monica
Rambo also known as Photon Monica is a
former sword agent who has a close
connection to Carol daners Monica then
got involved in a strange phenomenon in
Westview New Jersey where Wanda maximoff
had created a reality altering hex
barrier but crossing the barrier
multiple times caused Monica's cells to
be Rewritten resulting in her developing
superhuman abilities